first on CBS this morning a look at the
2019 Chevy Camaro before its public
debut General Motors took extraordinary
measures to keep the reboot off the
classic a of the classic a secret our
Kris Van Cleave got special access to
see how GM hides vehicles in plain sight
while testing them chris is outside the
CBS broadcast Center good morning good
morning we promise we will show you the
new Camaro in a second you'll get a good
look at it but for a car maker you can
spend hundreds of millions of dollars
developing a new vehicle so secrecy is
key but for months now GM engineers have
been driving the new camaro and using
new technology and this camo wrap on the
car to hide it in plain sight you might
see it as we're out driving today why
because that is the future driving by
hidden in plain sight this is considered
a high security vehicle right now high
security vehicle it has to be covered
when it's stopped but even heavily
disguised in its zebra colored camo the
brand new 2019 Chevrolet Camaro attracts
attention so how long after you drive
the 2019 Camaro off the proving grounds
for the first time there's a spy photo
show up normally the same day the Camaro
erupted onto the auto scene in 1967 to
take on Ford's Mustang through the years
and multiple design changes it's become
an icon for General Motors so secrecy is
key pictures not only ruin the surprise
for customers and tip off competitors
they can also hurt business people are
so enthusiastic and passionate about the
cars they want the latest and greatest
thing and so when they recognize we're
going to evolve the design they may hold
off buying so car makers have developed
an array of trickery from heavy vinyl to
disguise the cars shape and look - brand
new flash molded pieces transforming the
front and rear of a vehicle to hide the
new design underneath the body is
wrapped in dizzying camo to fool the eye
even the engine gets covered it's not
just what you see outside when you get
inside the car
everything in here is camouflage to the
dashboard the steering wheel even the
seats the work is done at this secret GM
facility where prototypes of future
models are built a team of three will
spend hours disguising a vehicle before
it leaves the plant here's the fender
feature line our camouflage engineers
would take this foam and they would
create a fake feature lines
I'll open Heiser leads the Camaro team
you could actually put a competitor's
brand on the front if he wanted to
really have some fun with the
photographer's he took us for a ride at
GM's proving grounds usually off-limits
to cameras we're trying out the new
10-speed transmission in the v8 Camaro
SS it's fast every GM vehicle gets
tested here here comes one so that's
nothing that's the brand new 2019 Chevy
Silverado 1500 so that already debuted
Brian Williams is an auto Spy
photographer who sells pictures of new
vehicles to websites and magazines from
the new presidential limo in camo two
Chevy's Malibu or this Jeep pickup
dubbed the scrambler what's the greatest
thing you've gone to get a photo of a
car getting a phone call and driving 17
hours through the night a good reason to
use more than just a little smoke and
mirrors to protect this secret
there it is here's the 2019 Chevy Camaro
it's got a new front this is a new paint
color CBS this morning continues after
your local news